glorious all hail the mighty man
whoa-ha-ha see compressed and his pupa
and welcome to jackass yeah keep going
captain ah [ __ ] yo and your mood go man
is it a plane is it a bird no it's the
average man will he'd reach the seafront
will he do it it's actually real
offensive he has another epileptic
seizure
what happened to his face rubber man he
became Darth Vader
robber man is my best friend my best
friend is rubber man no he's going
against will someone stop rubber man why
why is this too thick yeah go rubber man
[ __ ] yeah
rubber man don't take [ __ ] for nobody
okay oh god no no no no no no he's break
dancing
don't let rubber man break dance oh [ __ ]
the base is to drop out to drop no no no
no no no no drop the baby oh he has a
friend now oh he's moving closer to his
friend we're witnessing love I can show
you a dick my rubber man penis won't you
just touch it rubber man you're touching
my junk my rubber man man has a
threesome
Oh God he's going for the rubber
buttocks no it's just a dance oh god no
he's just working he's just working on
rubber what happens now oh it looks like
robber robber man is going to space Wow
he's flying rubber man where is he going
he clearly has a higher calling oh god
no oh no he crashed no he's flying again
in perfect
another crashing
think I broke the game he is the chosen
one oh my god
oh my god what is that all right how
about you know what this is gonna sound
crazy but level with me here how about
we just play the actual game no no I
know it's never been done on this
channel before but I have a good feeling
that it might be entertaining anyway
okay so here we have them anyway let's
pretend that we're a school mom and we
need to drive our kids to school and be
really [ __ ] short on time my god we
made that jump like a [ __ ] boss Wow
holy [ __ ] this is amazing checkpoint one
what's checkpoint - oh my god there it
is alright alright alright it looks like
all my children died in horrible car
accident can we make it up this hill
I'll be a note god damn it
let's try this [ __ ] again boy come on
kids that's rat [ __ ] holy [ __ ] this is
terrifying Wow
yeah boy ah yeah nailed it why are you
staring right oh my god now let we're
gonna have to get some speed for this
[ __ ] Oh God okay never go
yeah [ __ ] yeah
Ellen keep going captain keep going
captain captain stay let's do this again
do it again oh my god whatever don't do
it again
I don't want it was a daughter to get it
okay this is a new level we can we can
do this I'm sure we can do this level
I'm so good at driving brush wouldn't
you want to drive with me one day yeah
it's nice it'll be nice and relaxing
back Wow Oh God yep no we're fine we're
fine we're this happens every time I
Drive every time I Drive it's not a
problem
really look we're fine may have bumped
your head in a little bit name that's
why you should always wear a helmet
Oh God okay we made it through
checkpoint three out of eight I
sincerely doubt we can make it to the
end of this but damn it if we don't try
for out away that's a new record no ah
ah damn trees no [ __ ] me we became a
tree no no no
now I swore never to become a trade
daddy don't look at me don't look at me
how do I respawn a moose test yeah we do
that in Sweden
haha I had to do the moose test to get a
driver license so in Sweden there's a
lot of reindeers and mooses Mises
McDonald s my most Mises Moses Moses ah
so we have to be careful so yep this is
pretty spot-on
I got a moose ah moose ah - the moose
another moose you have to pretend the
mooses are there am I supposed to go
here now all right that's not the Moose
test yep now that I passed the moose
test trust me I know a thing this
happens every moose test don't worry
about it
the moose chest then continues of course
over yeah yes in this factory building
kill the moose
Oh God ah yeah Hey look we we're passing
the Moose test with flying colors let's
try that again
nail that moose test I did it that was
it that was [ __ ] it well [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you and your [ __ ] moves in the ass
I'll pass the moose test ah [ __ ] yo and
your moose your moose and me [ __ ]
moose
your [ __ ] moves your [ __ ] moves
[ __ ] come on dis Luke drag faster how
about you suck my moose dick ya know I
broke the game again
the car is flying it's literally flying
why was it because I offended you Moses
yeah of course I use more hey thank you
bros for watching this video I pass the
mood stairs
alright there's there's a glitch clear
glitch in the video games industry
there's misogyny everywhere like if you
enjoyed this video hit subscribe
converted I think it was so much for
watching bros and supporting this
channel what would I do without you
alright as always see you next video
stay awesome bros take us to Heaven's
co-op you
Oh goddamnit